J'imagine que tu ne te rappelle pas ce que tu faisais le 14 décembre 2015 n'as-tu pas senti quelque chose de bizarre parce qu à
11h51 exactement l'espace autour de toi c'est tout d'un coup dilater le d'un
ralenti puis tout s'est accéléré la pièce autour de toi s'est
contracté et tout est revenu à la normale ce que tu as expérimenté jour là le passage d'une onde
gravitationnelle tu l'as compris on va taper dans la crème le nectar des phénomènes physiques pourquoi les ondes gravitationnelles ne sont pas censées exister
pourquoi c'est si dur de les détecter et surtout pourquoi elle révolutionne autant notre vision du monde
les ondes gravitationnelles n'aurait jamais dû exister dans onze gravitationnelle ya
gravitation q c'est la force qui nous cloue au sol et qui retient les planètes sur leur orbite comme tous les concepts scientifiques
l'idée de la gravitation a beaucoup évolué au cours de l'histoire pendant longtemps on n'aurait jamais imaginé que la gravité puisse produire des ondes
par exemple dès l'antiquité
aristote déclarent plus les objets sont lourds plus ils tombent but ah oui tu lâches une boule de pétanque et une balle de tennis
elles n'ont pas la même vitesse mais plus tard galilée va montrer que si on enlève tous les frottements
genre l'air tous les objets tombent à la même vitesse
c'est le principe d'inertie en l'absence d'air comme sur la lune la gravité fait tomber plus et marteau à la même vitesse
cependant celui qui va vraiment faire le lien entre la chute des corps et les planètes ça sera newton et en
observant tomber des pommes il se dit tiens tiens
pourquoi les objets tombent vers le bas et pourquoi dans ce cas là la lune ne nous tombe pas sur la gueule parce que plus
les objets sont lourds et plus ils mettent une force attractive non j'ai pas raison oui même toi tu attires tout sur son passage
c'est une petite force de rien du tout mais elle est présent dress que dans le vide spatial de pommes qui n'iront
irrémédiablement pas s'attirer et finir en orbite l'une de l'autre
par contre la terre est assez grosse pour générer la gravité
nécessaire à nous retenir à sa surface et c'est comme ça que notre chien newton explique la gravité
on peut l'imaginer comme une sorte de cordes qui retient la terre autour du soleil et la lune autour de la terre et ça marche
très bien
le problème c'est que tout le monde sait que cette corde qui relie les planètes n'existe pas réellement alors de quoi est composé ce lien
invisible bon ça newton c'est peut-être un génie mais faut pas trop lui en demander il évite un peu le problème en supposant que boire
ça doit être une force qui se propage dans un truc proche du divin qu'on nommera les nerfs
il faudra attendre deux siècles pour éclaircir ce mystère début des années 1900 un petit bonhomme moustachu
tranquillement assis dans un fauteuil
s'amuse à appliquer la géniale méthodes des sciences poser des questions idiotes
ce monsieur moustache c'est le jeune albert einstein et il est en train de se demander si un jour on ne sait pas pourquoi
le soleil
décidé soudain de me faire un beau sur le côté comment la gravité serait perturbé selon pape sy newton c'est simple le changement de gravité
serait perçue instantanément dans tout l'univers peu importe la distance un trou noir qui naîtrait à 10 milliards d'années lumière
aurait une influence directe sur nous un film mais direct ça dans la tête d'einstein
ça colle pas le green intuition tellement folle que poser dans son fauteuil il se dit dans sa logique hein ça peut pas être
instantanée puisque j'ai montré que rien ne va plus vite que la lumière
du coup pas cette modification de la gravité peut pas être instantanée obligé elle doit se propager
il ya un truc qui manque dans la théorie newton et l' einstein ne va pas seulement ajouter une petite rustines pour rafistoler théorie newton
il va complètement bouleverser notre conception de la gravité de l'espace et du temps
Pour lui espace et temps sont
indissociables quand l'un est modifié l'autre aussi est plus un objet un espace important plus il déforme l'espace autour de lui qu'on peut facilement
visualisé en remplaçant l'espace par un drap
ainsi la trajectoire d'un astéroïde qui passe à côté de la terre n'est pas modifié parce qu'il est attiré justement par la terre à 90
sa trajectoire reste bien une vigne la sorite va tout droit ce qui est courbé
c'est l'espace dans lequel ils se déplacent et ça c'est une putain de révolution jusqu'à une cheville on a longtemps
considéré le temps comme une valeur absolue qui serait la même art ou du creux de ton lit au fin fond de l'univers
un maître reste partout à m et toutes les horloges
pendule d'autres fonds tic tac au même rythme fort et c'est là qu'entre en scène nos fameuses ondes gravitationnelles dans l'idée
l'espace-temps serait un petit peu comme une
immense piscine quand tu te déplaces de danse a fait des petites vagues des sortes d'ondulations qui s'éloignent progressivement
un trou noir qui se déplacent c'est pareil
il va provoquer des petites vaguelettes de gravité c'est à dire des ondulations de l'espace temps c'est pour ça qu'à stein déclare que tout objet
doté d'une masse qui se déplacent créer des ondes qu'on appelle ondes gravitationnelles
mais en faisant les calculs on se rend vite compte que c'est des changements de gravité de rien du tout pilote
nada même le soleil qui est très lourd et relativement proche de la terre ne produit que des bébés dont deux gravitationnelle minuscule
infinitésimale c'est pour sa canne stein va vite conclure qu'on ne l'ait détecterait
jamais sauf qu'il est bien gentil secret albert hockey ces calculs semble cohérent mais tant qu'on peut rien observé
concrètement en sciences ça n'a aucune validité et le problème d'albert c'est que les expériences
c'est pas trop jour des livres le gars j'ai une théorie de dingue j'ai appelé ça la relativité générale
sauf qu'on pourra jamais observer nous le prouver mais dans ma tête ça marche qui qui qui est avec moi
Bien sûr on a observé des trucs qui laissait sentir qu indirectement
il avait eu du flair genre une déviation des rayons lumineux lors d'une éclipse on le décalage de l'orbité de mercure
si bien qu'on s'est résolu à adopter la théorie de la relativité générale et c'est concret par exemple sans la relativité générale
les gps se trouve près d'une dizaine de kilomètres pourquoi pour deux raisons 1 les satellites en orbite autour de la terre
sont à très très très haute altitude
ils sont donc
1 un peu moins de gravité terrestre 2 les satellites vont très vite à plusieurs dizaines de milliers de kilomètres heure or en relativité générale
le temps est ralentie pour les objets en mouvement un pilote d'avion
vieillira plus ou moins vite seul ou dans quel sens il tourne autour de la terre à la vitesse d'un satellite
c'est suffisant pour que les gps est un décalage 30 microsecondes et c'est beaucoup en ce sens la relativité générale
nos gps ne marcherait pas mais bon voilà ce n'est pas une preuve pour l'existence des ondes gravitationnelles
oui jusqu'au 14 septembre 2015
la naissance des ondes gravitationnelles
Cette date va rester dans l'histoire de la physique c'est la première fois qu'on a enregistré une onde gravitationnelle ce jour-là
littéralement la terre à vibrer
ouais on imagine qu on a pris nos trois dimensions qu'on a tiré dessus comme si on y tire un tissu
peut-être qu'à ce moment là tu
étais dans une pièce tous les murs se sont écartés comme s'ils ont gonflé la pièce puis tout est revenu à la normale et la
tuque dixit a eu sa mi-temps souvient bray et but on a dit que les ondes gravitationnelles
et des très faibles en fait et c'est vrai mais ce jour là c'était pas n'importe quel ondes gravitationnelles
tout beau le soleil actu une idée d'à quel point ces
abusivement nous ce mastodonte pèse 330 mille fois la masse de la terre
maintenant que tu vois à peu près combien ça fait plein de soleil tu en prends 30 tu les prends touche
tous les compresses mais genre tellement fort que ça rentre dans une petite bille la boule que tu obtiens va tellement
compacte et dans ce qu'elle va former un putain de trou noir sauf que nous on va pas prendre une bille mais de beer
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans une galaxie très lointaine il y a très longtemps nos deux trous noirs notre miga mastodonte
infiniment danse et deux enfants du furet mutuellement leur attraction est tellement énorme qu'elle vous tournoyait ensemble à une vitesse mais
complètement folle jusqu'à ce qu'enfin
Là c'est un événement cataclysmique l'un des plus violents qui puisse exister dans l'univers en quelques instants des quantités
imaginables d'énergie sont dégagées l'équivalent de la masse de 3 soleil
instantanément
volatilisé en énergie pure ce plus que toute l'énergie produite en ce moment par toutes les étoiles de l'univers avec cette image in
l'espace temps est tellement froid c'est que la perturbation va se propager sur des années et des années lumière une onde de choc
mais dans le vide sauf qu'après un trajet 2 milliards d'années l'ondé tellement aimé que le déplacement n'excède pas dix
millième du diamètre d'un proto je vais essayer de te faire sentir à quel point c'est vraiment genre ont vraiment petit
imagine comprend un grain de sable etc on l'agrandît jusqu'à ce qu'il fasse la taille de la terre
à cette échelle
quelle place occupe les atomes du grain de sable
chaque atome aura gonflé pour atteindre la taille d'un terrain de basket et le noyau à tony par rapport à ça au centre du terrain
il sera aussi gros qu'un noyau de cerise mais même à ce niveau de zoom extrêmes le déplacement créé par l'ong gravitationnelle reste plus fin
que l'épaisseur d'un cheveu
d'un côté la fusion des trous noirs est si puissante qu'elle pourrait raser le système solaire de l'autre on a au final
fait sur la gravité comparable à fait multicouches
comment détecter l'un détectable le 14 septembre 2015 les scientifiques du monde entier
était prêt depuis cinquante ans plus d'un millier de physiciens de
mathématiciens
d'ingénieurs qui se sont lancés dans cet incroyable défi car c'est pas facile
il faut se creuser la tête parce que comment mesure une déformation de l'espace
si on utilisait une sorte de règle ultra-précise bas elle subira aussi la déformation de l'espace
donc on aurait toujours l'impression que rien ne se passe c'est pour ça qu'ils vont fuser une constante universelle
un nombre qui est le même partout en tout point de l'univers se montre
fondamental c'est la vitesse de la lumière et le type de lumière qu'on va accuser n'est pas choisi par hasard
il s'agit de la plus puissante et la plus précise qu'on sache produire un laser dont la fréquence est réglé au
poil près tellement puissant que tu pointes sur une bagnole
crabe elle se fait pulvériser même bombe à l'idée sera de séparer ce faisceau laser pour le faire passer par deux chemins différents
deux tubes sous vide spatial de 4 km de longueur
terminée par des miroirs arrivé au bout le rayon laser sera renvoyé puis recombiner on appelle ça un interféromètre
si les deux chemins étaient identiques pas de problème le signal n'est pas modifié mais si mignon
gravitationnelle perturbe le détecteur il ya un trajet dont l'espace temps va être un peu plus altérée que les autres et le signal au sort
de fait un peu décalé dans ces conditions quand les deux trajets se recombinent ils se superposent
peut tout à fait ce qu'on peut observer par une baisse de l'intensité du signal pendant un court instant
bon après ça se mesure à quelques photons sur plusieurs milliards alors comment être sûr que c'est pas des
micromouvements sismique de la terre ou même un chercheur qui a été retenu est d'abord les miroirs sont lisses à l'atome près et
l'ensemble du dispositif est suspendu pourront éviter les vibrations sismiques en plus les chercheurs ont un dernier atout il existe trois
interféromètre gravitationnelle sur terre s'il détecte la même anomalie au même moment il ya des choses
non gravitationnelle et c'est ce qu'on a conclu
après des mois de recherches d'analystes pour être sûr que c'est vrai toute cette belle aventure a bien mérité
trois prix nobel de physique et un français qui a eu le prix abel de mathématiques
rendez vous compte de l' aventure aristote galilée newton einstein tous ont tour à tour changer notre idée de la gravité
pourtant aucun d'eux n'aurait imaginé toutes les expériences tout le savoir-faire qu'on a pu mettre en oeuvre pour réaliser cette expérience
impossible le pire c'est que c'est maintenant presque banal on détecte des ondes gravitationnelles
quasiment tous les mois c'était là tous les jours en nous et on le voyait pas si vous aimez la science
pensez à vous abonner à notre chaîne saiosn strache la vidéo a été écrite par antoine un
passionné qui plus jeune a reçu le premier prix des olympiades de physique
sur ce sujet autant vous dire qu'on parle en passionné merci nous avons suivi ciao